it looks bad of course but it could have
been so much worse thankfully no one was
underneath the Drone when it was shot
down and crashed into this key of
building early on Wednesday morning
Svetlana cleared up the damage at her
father's flat just across the way
actually it's a good morning because
we're alive and this just glass it can
be removed and replaced it's not a big
deal
it's a stoicism born of experience for
months Russia has targeted Ukraine
cities and power infrastructure but
stoicism does not mean apathy it just
makes us very much angry very much
hungry this time the attack was a
failure
based on preliminary information all 13
drones were shot down by Ukrainian air
defense well done I'm sure of you dear
citizens we are grateful to the air
defense and don't ignore the sirens
but previous drone strikes particularly
when paired with cruise missiles have
been more successful since mid-october
Russia has damaged every one of
Ukraine's thermal power plants
and the Russian Stone of choice is this
they call them gerans but despite Russia
and Iran's denials they're widely
believed to be the Iranian maid Shah
head 136 and its smaller version the one
three one
altazira was given rare access to
recovered examples being studied by
Ukraine's Military Intelligence
yes this UAV does the most damage to us
because Russia uses it most often its
Warhead is 50 kilogram and the Warhead
of 131 is 20 kilograms
keeping his real identity secret vasil
told me what's inside them despite the
drones assumed Iranian Origins almost
all the components of foreign some are
even Ukrainian Talisman can another this
is from Canada
so that's interesting because it shows
that despite being under sanctions Iran
is still managing to get hold of
components like this some suggest
Russia's use of imported drones means it
has diminishing stocks of its own
Precision missiles but Ukraine knows it
can't be complacent despite the
destruction you see here it was a lucky
day for Kiev a hundred percent of the
Drone shot down no deaths and no
injuries but who's to say the next time
this happens they'll be so fortunate and
that's why Ukraine is making better air
defense one of the most important
requests it's making of its friends and
allies Rory challenge Al Jazeera Kiev